i was like all right bro look i don't
give a [ __ ]
if it don't work
i'm gonna try it at least i can say it
didn't once i tried you feel me so i was
like this pandemic we're gonna run it up
we got out filming every single day we
shoot all skits on a cell phone not even
an iphone on the um
on a on a samsung galaxy
s20 that's 20. that's the one and i edit
on my iphone so i keep both on me yeah i
mean i got my god the galaxy flick come
on but i got them both yeah yeah but
y'all know that galaxy that [ __ ]
the camera is best it's fire it's fire
it's just there's just no imessage
that's the only bad part about it and
emojis are shitty yes but if the galaxy
got the imessage i think your bubbles
weren't [ __ ] great oh bye-bye
that camera fires all of your skits are
shot on a cell phone yep all on a cell
phone edit on my uh iphone so you don't
even edit on a laptop no i had it i did
with my hands wow what program do you
use um
i'm i'm a tail i ain't never really told
it but i use imovie okay uh i use inshot
in this other app um called uh keen
master
king master yeah keen master so there's
literally no excuse if you're out there
master
there's no [ __ ] excuse no no excuse
everyone has a phone mm-hmm
[ __ ] if you if you need music
you got screen record
ah so if you need to put music in your
[ __ ] just screen screen record turn off
the turn off the notifications screen
record that [ __ ] straight
through
rip the audio from that layer it on the
video
and you do all that on your phone and
upload it to youtube all on my phone wow
like i'm i'm old school bro even when i
rap i i'll got notebooks like i i like
the value of using my hands
like being hands-on i like all your own
[ __ ] yeah edit all my own [ __ ] i'll be
up all night editing on my [ __ ] and if i
need to do a voice recording i'll go in
my closet close the door record like
that